together with our partner countries we
reiterated a need for a just peace that
respects Ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial Integrity both core
principles of the UN Charter
Russia started this war
and Russia had ended today by
withdrawing his troops from Ukraine
internationally recognized borders and
ceasing its assault
until then excuse me the ability
Ukraine's ability to defend itself is
essential to being able to end this war
permanently and through diplomacy you
know and this morning I once more shared
and assured president zielinski together
with all G7 members and our allies and
partners around the world that we will
not waver Putin will not break our
resolve as he thought he could two years
ago almost three years ago we're going
to continue to provide economic
humanitarian and security assistance to
Ukraine so it can stand strong as long
as it needs it and today the United
States announced our latest tranche of
artillery ammunition anti-tank weapons
and bridging equipment to help Ukraine
succeed in the battlefield
you know in my private meeting with
president zielinski after the G7 meeting
and with his staff I told the United
States together with our allies and
partners is going to begin training
Ukrainian pilots and fourth generation
fighter aircraft including f-16s to
strengthen Ukraine's Air Force as part
of a long-term commitment to Ukraine's
ability to defend itself we provided the
last year all that they needed to deal
with what they were dealing with at the
moment and that's when now we're moving
in the direction of putting them in a
position to be able to be defend
themselves in ways beyond what they've
had to deal with so far a flat Assurance
from the from zelinski that they will
not they will not use it to go on and
move into Russian Geographic territory